i've told you guys before that jared
kushner donald trump's son-in-law
is truly a sinister force in american
politics and
in the world and uh jared's back you
know after he did that one
coronavirus press briefing where he said
things like
you know the stockpile is our stockpile
it's not
a stockpile for the states they pulled
him out
of public view because he's been a
disaster now he's back jared kushner
reappearing on fox news yesterday
he was asked about the black american
community
and he brought us a beautiful message of
hope and unity which was hey listen
trump's policies have been the right
policies but
we can't make black people more success
successful than they want to be we can
only help them so much
we can't make them want to be successful
if they don't want to be successful i
guess that this was
how jared kushner thought he was
defending trump's policy
towards black americans and other
minority groups
i don't know but take a look at this
embarrassing fiasco
i think we've seen in a lot of the the
the black community which is mostly
democrat is that
uh president trump's policies are the
policies that can help people break out
of the problems that they're complaining
about
but he can't want them to be successful
more than they want to be successful and
what you're seeing throughout the
country now
is a groundswell of support in the black
community because they're realizing that
all the different bad things that the
media and the democrats have said about
president trump
are not true and so they're seeing that
he's actually uh deliberate he's put up
results and a lot of people want to get
on board to start working with president
trump because they know that
you know unlike most politicians who
have been in washington for decades who
talk and say all the right things
president trump may not always say the
right things but he does the right
things is this the right message days
before the election like maybe the
calculation is
by saying this eight days before an
election as he did yesterday
he'll bring in more of the racist vote
than the number of
other folks that will leave because of
the the message i don't know
and of course jared kushner's personal
lack of self-awareness
about wanting to be successful being
what matters
he was born with a silver spoon in his
mouth
had businesses handed to him by his dad
his dad essentially paid his way into
harvard
it is you know the height of lack of
self-awareness and hypocrisy it's just
another instance really
of the same projection we've been seeing
for years
with this family major transition into
the second term
it's not our fault they're just not
working hard enough we can only help
them succeed so much
the guy was born on third base and he's
telling actual
batters how to hit a triple that's the
best analogy i can think of for this and
honestly when people say this stuff out
loud
how does he walk around without getting
punched in the face is it just 24
7 security that keeps the guy from
getting slapped and by the way
this idea of a groundswell of support
for donald trump from the black
community
it's also a farce the latest ibd
poll has trump polling eight percent
with black voters another poll has trump
polling
seven percent with black voters there is
no ground swell of black support for
donald trump
now many republicans will say oh david
the reason black voters
aren't supporting trump is they've been
tricked by the democratic party
into essentially signing a blank check
for them and voting for democrats no
matter what
which is really a way of saying black
people aren't
actually evaluating candidates they've
been tricked
which i guess means they're not that
smart they've been tricked
into voting for the democratic party now
the truth is
black folks and hispanic folks and women
and the college educated and on and on
all these groups that are supporting joe
biden
they're doing it because they know what
trump offers
and they don't want it that's really the
reason black voters and others
aren't supporting trump but back to
jared kushner and the idea that trump
can only help help
black people so much they have to help
themselves
is this just a play for the racist vote
have they calculated
let's bring in more racist whites
we'll lose some black voters if jared
says this but will bring in more racist
whites who are overwhelmingly there's
more racist whites than black people
watching fox news uh in the morning
let's put
let's be let's be clear is it a
calculation or am i reading too much
into it there's no calculation it's just
jared being jared and that's it
as if you needed another reason to
remove trump
we might be only a week out from never
having to hear from
jared kushner again which for me is a
really great incentive to vote to remove
donald trump which i've already done
this really is a reminder that the right
has no policy
on broad-based economic stimulus for the
lower and middle class
regardless of race we can say the left's
policy isn't good enough
we can say the democratic party isn't
left enough
on economic policy but at least the left
thinks you need policy
jared and republicans have this idea you
can't help people if they won't help
themselves
if they won't pull themselves up by
their own bootstraps
to revitalize a completely ridiculous
idea
why can't poor people just decide to
stop being poor
jared kushner's frustrated that poor
people
keep deciding to be poor that's what
this comes down to
it's a malignancy and we've got to
remove it if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's
perfect if you don't have enough time to
do all the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video